So the website i09 which is it's
a very cool website so they did something
the seven Global apocalypse scenarios as
that might happen and we've got a couple
for your show you three quick ones
minimalism address
today than one that it likely that
endemic and
a pandemic disease love city life in
half our population lead
in 30 these is virulent
another humanity could be wiped out a
matter of mine this is our night movie
contagion.
which I really love a pandemic crop
diseases can be just as brilliant as
animal diseases because many farmers by
identical strains a staple crops from
Monsanto and other corporations
all their crops would be vulnerable to
the same infectious disease
so I forget to more real quick bolide
impact a bolide is a really large chunk
a matter from space often on fire that
can form a large crater when it smashes
into a planet I think the dinosaurs
might know something about this often
geologist will describe the event that
wiped out the dinosaurs as a bolide
impact there you go
one more large igneous provinces about
kato that doesn't explode instead a huge
crack open the earth's crust and lava
bubbles out
whizzing across the landscape really
think I'm the toxic gases and ash
and igneous province can we love a
person centuries overtime
that bill the atmosphere with poison
and Rex the environment and we've got a
couple more min to put them on hold
at those three do you have a favorite
which way deep in her hometown
had those three have heard your real
fatalist today so you must have 10
I don't know him well you know it may be
because he said it first a pandemic that
any sounds really viable
to her I mean I see these things getting
worse and worse and worse than we're
chasing after them with different to
vaccines and things are working
I think we want to root for the im the
meteor
in pack pride is the easiest way to go
to the quickest way down the virus seems
like maybe it's a possibility but it's a
bad way to go
a right not a camera I'd like to the
fast you I do what he actually hit by
the meteor
match are not a wave to conduct a
shopping know what
yeah at Walgreens yeah well I agree that
sounds like the pandemic he did you guys
see a movie can take k in which I want
to feel honored to be in it was great
but break that sort of slow
Creeping Death see my Gary although you
know they would know we have a couple
weeks probably
up knowing that the media was gonna head
which can you imagine all when know that
one in Russian 101 Russia came by we
know
a advance warning on that would be at
maybe we'll have a we can send what is a
Bruce Willis and an app like a little
bitter blow after another tear it up and
ready only have been at a comeback
yeah the hanger
yeah that's another terrible Michael Bay
movie
my my thoughts on transformers for by
the way opposed to me about that I have
a look at the other options that they
gave us
options the other ways we can probably
die
climate change okay bring the internet
so that is one over the next century or
more
changes will wreck our crops faster than
a band and then radiation disaster
atomic war nearby gamma ray bursts I get
this as I know the whole or a blast
%uh highly radioactive particles
streaming out of an exploding star
invasive species moving plants and
animals around the planet
where they have no natural predators and
Black Swan aside an improbable
development
that changes everything you gotta get
any favorite to these Miro scary and
they all seem
I think I am i believe the event is
horrified at me
climate change I'm kinda Jan happening
and we're gonna and you know we've
already seen the effects of
I've what happened when people don't
have access to clean water and there's a
are from fresh water and there's you
know some will argue that what's
happening in Syria as a result in this
and we're gonna see the next war some
course be fought over water
and while I'm on my way next hour week
to Bangladesh which is
you know there's millions and millions
of people who are under threat above
losing
where they live and where are those
people going to go we think that there's
an immigration problem now it's going to
be much worse when we write a lot of the
land the park including Los Angeles now
florida's and in a lot of trouble in New
York said you never sent alternative to
bring LAN
are suffering got here whether I ayzee
pandemic I don't know if anybody saw the
normal heart on HBO yeah
but I mean look what happened there when
the aids virus
came and people just for dining 9
swatched
each other dying in there was nothing
they can do about it
and that's just a little microcosm up
what can happen with all these buyers
the I so that time
yeah so that's actually perfect a
weighted manic-depression with you on
your cell line at nettuno
very I hi I'm which you hear more the
ones that we can't control or the ones
that week
had because something like nuclear war
me we we invented nuked
so we've had like Mad Hatter hand in
some other stuff some a bit if an
asteroid come to
you know we can try to stop it but it
doesn't thing to do with something that
we did
here which one do you fear would happen
for sure do you fear one more
where thing about humanity we want to
destroy ourselves we build news all over
the place
and guess what you build chip using not
much how it works I think that you can
control
you can control well liked what you want
about myself
yeah the benefit it's all the things
that permit personally for me that you
can control that give me more stress
yeah
because I feel like I should be able to
do something about that does what are
they doing something about that yeah I
do think that the
the most by a where we're going in to
see the most problems is gonna be in
with what happens when the climate
it is going to be that rather than
nuclear war and then the third one is
artificial intelligence which i think is
something that
I'm people don't are as worried as they
should be
what do I ever gonna be here I am here
and there that they're gonna lie DSL for
an
they're going to turn out like hell well
how yeah exactly
yeah we don't know we don't know what's
going to happen when artificial
intelligence happens which is coming up
in Brighton few decades but no
you know for people out there are a lot
of people who are I'm not optimistic
about it like makers around and there
are people who are scared about you may
ask for the winter break her as well
optimistic you can be controlling all
damn day until it turns on him and kill
him
offense any honey advances that we make
are
ultimately can end up destroying that
mean you look at all the advances that
we have
yeah so final play listen will did the
beginning with government has plans
for any reason we do they really have
contingencies for anything
love you saw their incredible response
to both Katrina and Hurricane sandy I
shot a backpack very prepared for
whatever is covered be a
wedding you think they have a is there a
pile somewhere
you know that we don't know everything
as you alluded to i i can't. I'm sorry
there have been times I have no idea
yeah
not and now I really don't know it's
like who knows I mean I can barely
handle like you like all the things that
we think they're handling and then
there's also other files in the back i
mean i i can't even fathom it I'm sorry
that's exactly what I am doing the show
folks can we don't know every going to
talk about it